[Music]
welcome to this dw business special
where we're asking will a cap on russian
oil prices work
since its invasion of ukraine russia has
been able to fund its war by selling its
oil around the world but now the g7
group of advanced economies says it
wants to put an end to that by limiting
the amount of money russia can make the
likes of the uk us germany and japan
plan to cap the price they're willing to
pay for russian oil
so will the cap work how high will they
set it and will other countries come
aboard to answer these questions and
more i'm joined by professor jeffrey
sonenfeld from yale school of management
he and his team have been carrying out
unparalleled research into the impact of
the war on russia's economy it's great
to have you with us again jeffrey
rob it's fantastic to be with you again
and i just love that introduction thank
you very much
i hope it uh sum things up well enough
and let's get straight into it why does
the g7 believe that there is a need for
this cap on russian oil prices
yeah that's an excellent question
because the status quo is not that bad
uh you might wonder because the status
quo uh people are some are saying well
putin has set himself up as this great
savvy world energy czar are
smirking and the reality is he's not is
in fact there as we have spoken before
that gas is not fungible and the gas
that is not going into
the eu uh can't pivot and go into asia
because
uh as you recall we spoke last time the
the the pipelines needed to transport
vapor gas that which is all russia
produces they don't produce liquefied
natural gas that can be shipped it has
to go through has to go through these
pipelines those pipelines that don't
exist one little creaky one but so 86 of
their gas that was going into europe now
they can only get a fraction of it in
there so gas prom is down by a third
but and they've got problems on that
meanwhile uh the eu has all the gas
they're going to need it's going to be
more expensive gas but there's no limit
it's uh it's it's like saying that there
are plenty of cars that have to be
mercedes uh rather than kias they're
more expensive because it's liquefied
natural gas a lot that's coming in there
but already uh
germany which was say pulling in about
43 percent of its gas from russia uh is
now getting less than 10 it's mainly
from the u.s and norway and it'll be a
lot more soon and we as we already know
we're already at 85 percent of our
winter storage is already there way
before we were last year but your
question is about oil and oil people are
saying yeah but
but people are still making russia still
making money off of oil and it's that's
why your questions are going because in
fact they're not making that much what's
wrong with the status quo uh they're
they're they're a very inefficient
producer and the only places they can
sell the oil right now largely our
are india and china and india china have
gotten such big discounts that they're
pretty much working just about break
even so while the revenues are higher
the profits are not well the reason
then that the status quo won't work
because i kind of like the status quo is
that we have sanctions coming in which
will stop all crude oil uh from being
sold and then uh in in eu and elsewhere
uh by december 5th
and then we're going to have by february
5th all refined products of gasoline and
things like that
of petrol petro products so
that could lead to some oil shocks so
this is a very smart move to try to
figure out how do we allow for the fact
that the oil will flow elsewhere we're
going to put a cap on those prices uh
and uh there's a real incentive then for
the rest of the world
to uh to enforce these uh these oil caps
so that's the reason why because of
what's coming on uh december
how does how's the cap actually work in
in practice though how do you make sure
that companies are only spending a
certain amount when they buy a barrel of
russian crude
uh well it's um
we know what a country is paying for it
uh and a shipper uh a maritime insurer
all the traders
all the people who handle the
third-party logistics that make that
possible is you know some i don't know
90
of the of the fuel that's being shipped
is on uh is on eu or or uh or uk
ships and certainly financed uh insured
by uh eu or uk maritime insurers and
they're going to be subject to these
laws some skeptics would say oh that
won't work these are the same skeptics
who said it wouldn't work for all kinds
of
of
of other anti-terrorism uh
sanctions and things like that where
every financial state institution was
held to it and those who cheated were
held response criminally responsible and
uh and they now toe the line so we have
a good history for enforcing this and
it's the third parties that'll enforce
it and they have a very strong incentive
to do so we have a great history of
showing it works
yeah we'll talk about uh those skeptics
that you just mentioned in a moment but
what has russia's response been well
president putin insists that such a move
by g7 nations who are already struggling
with high energy prices would backfire
back on themselves
we will not supply anything at all if it
is contrary to our interests in this
case our economic interests we will not
supply gas oil coal or fuel oil
but those who are trying to impose
something on us are in no position today
to dictate their wills they should come
to their senses
should we take president putin at his
word there could russia simply stop
supplying its oil to the g7 and
countries that also participate in this
if there's a big top-line message from
our discussion this morning rob is that
nobody on the planet should ever take
president putin at his word on anything
other than perhaps that his name is
vladimir putin everything after that you
shouldn't believe he invented his gdp
number and conceal as we talked last
time concealed all of his national
income statistics to support it so now
the imf and everybody else realizes that
they were duped uh that's a fake number
and his currency the rupal is just an
arbitrary number he assigned it's not a
traded currency and on this front uh
he's trying to present himself as if as
if this is a supplier's market he's the
the oil supplier it's a buyer's market
he knows that but he's trying to weaken
uh eu resolve eu unity by suggesting oh
you're going to suffer this is not going
to lead to increased prices the whole
idea of a cap is that it's imposing
lower prices if he says
president putin isn't the only one
saying this is is he i've heard people
comparing this as you know going into a
shop and demanding that the shopkeeper
sells you their products for less i mean
could this actually result in in in
driving up prices in the wider oil
market
and this is what happens when you have
open bargaining is sometimes set prices
don't work and so in fact uh any skeptic
who said that to you should realize that
uh in in two weeks the back to school uh
bargains will be everywhere because
everything's going to be discounted
because consumers want
are not paying the premium september
prices uh late august or early september
prices for the back to school goods that
in fact they get reduced the prices
aren't set and consumers sometimes it's
a buyer's market as it will be without a
stock merchandise uh
in your retail example and that's how
it's also going to be with oil is
he has to sell it more than the world
has to buy it it's 60 percent of his
cash starved revenue his nation
especially with this war machine he has
to fuel uh the only thing that putin
could should hope for is that somehow
the russians develop an otherworldly uh
capability to not be poisoned by
drinking oil and that he himself because
that's all he's going to have if he
refuses to sell it he'd be better he
better be pretty good about drinking it
directly as a beverage because they need
this for this they need this way more
than the rest of the world needs it he
has to sell that fuel uh and he can't
just stop selling it it's again 60 of
his revenue if he shut down those wells
we're still because of where we shut
down wells even even in the u.s and shut
down some some pumping because of march
of 2020 reduced demand during the peak
of covid we are still bringing some of
those wells back up and this is with far
superior technology here in the u.s than
he has in russia if he shuts those
things down it's going to be years
before they could even get back into it
so it would be devastating for them they
can't take their toys and leave he can't
take his ball and run it's not his ball
game so that's that's what he it's a a
false premise he's working off of
okay well since the russian invasion of
ukraine western nations have you know
already been dramatically reducing their
consumption of russian oil the united
states has banned imports and perhaps
more significantly the eu is uh phasing
in an embargo however as professor
sonfeld already mentioned other nations
have been taking up some of the slack
notably in asia china's imports remain
consistent meanwhile india is importing
considerably more russian oil than it
was before the invasion it's gone from
basically uh none to close to a million
barrels per day so jeffrey sonnenfeld
can a price cap on russian or work
without the likes of india and china
being on board
india and china will will be some of the
most enthusiastic proponents of this uh
because what there as the uh the indian
energy minister just said this week he
said we'd be interested but not for
reasons perhaps of of global morals
we're interested in what's the moral
comparative we feel is how do we get the
cheapest energy for india so that seems
uh so this gives them more bargaining
power is that is that what he's
referring to yes they
they get the energy cheaper why would
they possibly want to pay more this they
have absolutely on our side on this and
and by by the way
again just because russia is selling
more to india that was temporary all
indian storage is now
capability is almost filled china is
still buying this week but russia has
tapered off this week they don't have
any place to put it in closets or
drawers or people's desks they they kind
of run out of places to put and they
can't believe they're getting it so
cheap because it's so much a buyer's
market that uh that india that india and
china have exacted a 35 a barrel
discount on oil that which is selling
for 80 some dollars a barrel right now
if you believe putin or you believe jp
morgan's energy analyst we'd be paying
400 a barrel for energy right now and
guess what they were wrong it's around
80 82 83 84 a barrel so with a 35 disc
discount they're paying 50 a barrel to
get oil
it costs russia 44 45 a barrel to
extract it they're break even they're so
inefficient yes russia is opec's third
largest energy producer and they are the
least efficient venezuela amazingly with
antiquated technology is a more
efficient producer it costs russia twice
as much
to
pull the oil out of the ground as it
costs the saudis the saudis is 22 a
barrel so they're not making very much
money right now uh but they're making
something and uh and they need that
something
actually some of the the things you've
said there are also what i've heard
echoed from the united states government
which is really leading uh the charge
with the price cap plan let's hear why
the americans think it is such a good
idea let's get the view from the white
house
a global price cap will help us
accomplish our two goals the first one
is significantly reduce putin's biggest
source of revenue for his war chests
number two ensure that oil continues to
flow into the market at lower prices and
supply meets demand the impact of our
efforts to implement a price cap is
already bearing fruit reports show that
russia is already offering steep
discounts as much as 30 percent and
long-term contracts to some countries
this also demonstrates that russia is
planning to continue supplying its oil
and willing to swallow bigger discounts
russia is willing to to swallow bigger
discounts and actually to accept less
money for its oil which i think is what
you've
predicted it would happen in the event
of a price cap and how it would have to
accept less from the likes of india but
what i want to ask you is
when it comes to actually setting the
price cap
how do you go about doing that
presumably you don't set it at below
russia's
production cost
well
as you know uh there aren't many bigger
critics of russia on the planet than am
i
however i'm almost worried that it would
so discourage them we have to make sure
exactly to your point rob that we we
allow a little bit of incentive a little
bit of profit for them but russia is so
bad right now it's hard even though even
though the top-line revenues are there
it's hard to insure them just barely
enough of a profit so they they it's
worth it for them to do it at all
because uh right now it's quite slim so
if we're looking at a
a barrel cap which is saying being
discussed or somewhere in that vicinity
that's a very thin margin i don't think
we could go any lower than that it's
very close to the break even for russia
i should also point out that russia
pulling it out of the ground at 44 a
barrel
or a little bit more is very expensive
but they still have to pay the shipping
cost to send their oil
oh to get it into uh into
the eu
uh it's maybe um uh one to two
perhaps three days uh to get it to these
ports uh ports in asia we're talking
about it's 34 days that's a lot of
expensive time in shipping uh so that
also erodes that tiny profit margin it
is uh
russia if you're going to cut the the
profit margin down so so low is to make
it almost
financially unviable for the russians
why not just
ban imports of russian oil
because we still want it in the global
marketplace why why take that supply
away and and drive up uh
opec pricing this way uh we very
effectively reverse you know i think
opec could be a little bit nervous
people have wondered why hasn't there
been a buyer's cartel for years because
we've had this
fairly effective sellers cartel with
opec so i think we saw a little bit of
inconsequential um maneuvering by the
saudi arabia and and the opec some of
the major opec producers this past week
uh but it didn't it was very tiny uh but
you could see that they chafe a little
bit at just how effective a buyer's
cartel can be there'll always be a
little bit of an incentive to cheat by
the way in any cartel that's always the
case but it doesn't matter everybody's
prices still are coming down
dramatically and we just should give
them
we don't want to
cut off a hundred percent of russian oil
in the market we just don't want putin
making any money out of it and this is
china of course has come to this
realization china knows they'd love to
have russian oil
there's no evidence any longer that
china is so any backer of vladimir putin
we've just seen uh some of russia's uh
top physicists were last week were
imprisoned for uh espionage on behalf of
of china and there are a couple other
frictions that you probably have seen in
the geopolitical flare-ups between
russia and china in just the last 10
days that are quite noteworthy so
there's no patron saint of china
protecting uh protecting russia the way
they've protected north korea
okay well as well as a proposed cap on
oil russia may soon have to
have his ability to make money from gas
curtailed as well as professor sonifer
was also mentioning up top the eu has uh
it was his biggest export partner before
the war when it came to natural gas but
eu ministers have now been meeting in
brussels to discuss putting a cap on the
amount member states pay for russian
natural gas the block has already
significantly reduced its gas imports
from russia and moscow has been
gradually choking off its supplies as
well it just holded supplies down a key
pipeline nordstrom one indefinitely as
well so jeffrey sonnenfeld
can russia afford to fight this on both
the gas and the oil front
uh russia has no leverage to fight on
either front uh on on the gas front
shutting down nordstrom one as he has
there's still there are still two other
pipelines uh as you know that are
getting ample supplies of russian uh uh
gas into the eu if those two were shut
down it's still not an issue it's only
we've we've just you know since you and
i have had conversations this spring
that it's fallen from 46 44 44 to 46
percent of german and and pretty similar
for overall eu supplies of gas into
russia to now less than 10 percent if
you were to cut off that 10 percent that
will very easily be replaced by
liquefied natural gas that hasn't even
yet started to go into
into germany from the u.s from algeria
from a lot of other sources that have
lng shipments ready to go in there
germany brilliantly started these six uh
conversion plants massive conversion
plants from liquefied natural gas lng to
be converted into the vapor that goes
throughout the eu
it's
a crisis is is is worrisome if people
don't pay attention to it having the six
months notice we now see that germany
has has built been building these plants
immediately they were not even on the
drawing board it's just it's incredible
this is going to be one of the real
miracles of infrastructure that these
massive conversion plans will be done in
december and by the way the 15
voluntary rationing that the eu agreed
to surprised all of us uh spain and
portugal didn't have much incentive to
go along with this and of course a lot
of times we've seen independent streaks
in hungary and turkey it's a and a lot
of the media and frankly a lot of
political scientists were shocked that
three weeks ago three weeks ago
yesterday the eu's unanimously adapted
that 15 percent adopted that 15
rationing which may not even be needed
but these are like wartime maneuvers and
for efficiency so this is where it uh
the using great just i'm not saying
it isn't going to be more expensive but
it's not going to be a cold winter it's
going to be a little bit more expensive
and hard on certain certain heavy
industry uh because of what it's going
to mean for the pricing of energy uh
short term
okay professor jeffrey solindell i know
you've got to to head off now so i will
i will thank you most heartily for uh
fielding our questions here on this dw
business special thank you for everyone
also who's been watching as well special
thanks to jeffrey sonenfeld from yale
school of management and also uh do
remember to check out more of our videos
here on youtube if you've enjoyed this
one may i humbly recommend our latest
edition of business beyond which is on
how to make money in the metaverse until
next time thank you very much and take
care